what's quite powerful about poetry is
because it doesn't really have much of a
money market place it has always
survived it is not dependent on
patronage it is not dependent on you
know people going out and buying books
so that the poet can stay in shoe
leather you know poets always know that
we have to support ourselves in other
ways and so I think that that
paradoxically perhaps that's a very good
set of conditions with which to know
that if you must make your art you will
continue to make your art it also is an
inexpensive art form when you think
about it I mean you know there are no
real supplies yes it takes time and time
is money but I think poetry has always
found its way you know it's it's grass
in the in the cement cracks
I would say first of all that it never
hurt anybody which is to say go ahead
and try it right i mean you know there's
sort of no risk involved i think that
when people get all carried away and and
you know unhappy about feeling that
poetry is being forced upon them my
response is often what's it you know
what's it going to hurt you or anybody
else if you read this poem what's going
to happen if you take five minutes and
read this poem so that's to begin with
and i think that you know poetry arrests
us in wonderful ways it makes us look at
the material world in ways that we might
not have thought otherwise so you know
the tremendous reward of a common object
situation feeling emotion described in
language that makes us understand it
more deeply more richly a little bit
differently is one of poetry's great
great gifts and rewards the moment of
pause that in essence embodies the value
of meditation the value of not hastening
through every utterance in every moment
the necessity of stopping and rethinking
sometimes all of that is what poetry
kind of models for us and I think that
what we ask poets in particular to do
artists as well but poets in particular
is to dig deeply in emotional
Wellsprings in in the sort of fields of
experience to dig deeply also in the
language and in a sense do the feeling
for those who at that moment can't
you